never I'd like to introduce today's
featured presenter Pamela Hines
Pamela Hines is a professor of
management science and engineering in
the School of Engineering at Stanford
University the director of the Center
for work technology and organization and
faculty director of the School of
Engineering global engineering programs
for students pamela studies the effect
of technology on groups she's
contributed extensive research on the
dynamics of geographically distributed
work teams particularly those spanning
national boundaries she explores issues
of culture language emotion conflict and
the role of site visits and promoting
trust and collaboration most recently
she's been exploring the relationship
between national culture and work
practices especially innovation
practices pamela has also been exploring
the relationship between national
culture and technology use and is
interested in the design of
collaborative technologies for use
across natural boundaries national
boundaries now I'll turn it over to
Pamela okay sherry said I'm going to be
talking a little bit today about us
versus them overcoming differences to
inspire collaboration many of you are
probably working in teams that are
spanning a variety of different kinds of
boundaries working with people who are
maybe in a different location even in a
different country from a different
discipline in a different organization
and so forth and all of those
differences can really lead to positive
outcomes but can also be challenging for
people and that's what we're going to
talk about today so one premise and this
is something that was mentioned by an
article by Forbes diversity is a key
driver for innovation and that is
something that is generally believed to
be true what we've seen over the last
couple of decades is that more and more
organizations are looking to diversity
as a way to bring in different
perspectives and drive higher levels of
innovation there was a survey that was
done by Forbes of c-level executives
around the globe and they asked them
you know does a diverse inclusive
workforce is it crucial to encouraging
different perspectives and ideas that
drive innovation 48% of the people
surveyed strongly agreed with that
statement
37% somewhat agreed so a very large
percentage of the respondents really do
believe that having a diverse inclusive
workforce helps bring in these different
perspectives and increase the innovation
potential of an organization so another
quick poll in your opinion does working
across boundaries actually increase
innovation will have been 10 seconds for
you to complete the poll if you don't
think it really helps at all you could
answer one or a if you think that it's
really crucial for innovation you can
answer e or five very much okay so the
poll has ended and we're going to take
just a few seconds to pull up the
results of that okay here we go and what
we're seeing is you know just like the
executives that were pulled around the
globe you know many people you know seem
to think that you know it probably leads
to higher levels of innovation or even
you've got 127 respondents that said
that it's very important it very much
leads to innovation so let's look at
what the research shows it actually
depends does working across boundaries
increase innovation you know that the
you know some of the research suggests
that there are real benefits and some of
it suggests that in fact we're not
seeing higher levels of innovation
there's some work done by Lee Fleming at
Harvard and he looked in particular at
diversity in team members disciplines or
backgrounds or functional expertise
and then map that against the value of
innovation that they were producing in
these teams and there are two really
important things that you'll see if you
look closely at this graph one is that
the average value of innovation actually
goes down as you get more diversity on
the teams so that's a little bit
surprising given that you know we really
think and hope that higher levels of
diversity should actually lead to more
innovation but the other thing that's
really interesting about this slide is
that the only time you see breakthrough
innovations the only time that you see
really high levels of innovation is when
you have this diversity in the teams and
what this tells us and actually a lot of
research that's been done on a variety
of different kinds of diversity
including ethnic diversity gender
diversity diversity and national
background and so forth
all of that research shows that
oftentimes you do see a decrease in
innovation and a decrease in performance
when you have a lot of diversity in
teams but it's also an opportunity for
really high levels of innovation but the
challenge is managing those teams it
takes a little bit more effort and
attention to manage teams with higher
levels of diversity
and a couple of elements so first of all
we've got a lot of different kinds of
diversity on the left side of this slide
and what really has to happen that what
has to be managed in order to get the
diversity or get the innovations that a
team is looking for first is you have to
actually get the information out you
know the benefits of diversity is you
have these different perspectives you
have different kinds of information that
people have access to but sometimes it's
a little bit challenging to get all that
information out in a way that it can be
used toward innovation and in the team
and then the second element is once
you've got the innovate the information
out you see that people are seeing these
from different perspectives how do you
then integrate those different
perspectives how do you bring that
together so that you're you're
developing something new as a result of
it
so let's dive a little bit down into the
first one getting information out to
achieve their innovation potential teams
need to first be able to get the
information on the table you know if you
don't share these perspectives then
what's the point of working across
boundaries at all a couple different
things that have to happen here one is
it really helps if the team has a
learning orientation and that's
something that can be influenced by the
culture of the organization influenced
by the leader of the organization people
really need to want to learn from others
they want to believe that learning these
different perspectives is actually going
to help them to be more successful in
achieving their goals they also need to
anticipate that there are going to be
alternative viewpoints when they go into
a meeting it turns out that if people
walk into a meeting knowing that they're
going to hear very different viewpoints
they come with a different mindset and
are better able to process those
different viewpoints so you know letting
people know that that's valued and that
they should expect that and there's also
really important that people feel valued
and safe people will not share their
different perspectives if they feel like
their perspective is not going to be
appreciated heard and so forth and then
finally it just takes more time you know
when everybody shares the same
perspective you've got a lot of common
ground it's really easy to talk quickly
through things but when people have
really different perspectives often much
more explanation is needed in order for
people to understand those different
viewpoints and that just takes time and
then once you've got the information out
the next hurdle is integrating this
diverse information people need to
understand the relevance of what it is
they've heard and if people are coming
from really different perspective it can
be challenging to see how what somebody
else is offering fits the way that
you're thinking about the the problem
that you're working on so you know in
some times it can just be hard to relate
to and make sense of what somebody else
is saying a couple things that are
really helpful in that one is again it
takes time there needs to be more
conversation more discussion about these
different perspectives in order to see
the relevance in order to figure out
where there is common ground in the
different viewpoints that are being
brought together and that helps to
overcome what's called a
representational gap which is that when
people particularly are coming from
different disciplinary perspectives they
often have different ways that they have
been trained to represent the problem
and again you know if you can take the
time for people to really articulate how
they're representing the problem how
they're prioritizing different elements
of it then that can help people to find
opportunities for common ground so we're
going to focus on today is the us versus
them dynamic that that interferes with
all of these processes so that's one of
that as leaders you can work on
addressing in your teams and that's
effective you know whether you're
cross-organizational cross-functional
across geography cross-cultural and so
forth it turns out that the
us-versus-them dynamic that you see in
these teams is one of the most pervasive
problems that we see in cross boundary
teams one of these things that is is
just it's so human you know we have this
natural tendency to subgroup into
different groups that are similar to
ourselves and this is something that
just naturally happens in these teams
and I'll talk a little bit today about
why that happens and what we can do
about it but first I'm going to ask you
a couple of questions and then I'll just
wait a few seconds you might want to
just write down a couple of your answers
so each of these I'd like you to answer
why you think this might have happened
so the first one is a colleague that
you're working with in Amsterdam
regularly gets up and leaves your
teleconferences early at 4:50 p.m. their
time instead of 5 o'clock p.m. so just
make a couple of notes about why they
might be doing this all right and then
the next one
a co-worker from marketing gives you
misleading information why might that
have happened again just take a few
seconds to jot down a couple notes all
right the third one is a colleague from
another company that you're working with
sends you an analysis that's badly
flawed why might that have happened
okay so for each of these there are many
possible responses you know for the
colleague and Amsterdam you might have
said that they had a train to catch
and it you know only leaves hourly and
they need to get home to their family
you might have said that they're lazy
but they're uncommitted these are all
answers that I've gotten before to this
question for the second one you might
say that you know the person is
incompetent so they gave you misleading
information or they've got another
agenda that they're working you might
have also said that you know they're
they just have a different way of
explaining things because they're from a
different field for the third one you
might have said that you know the person
misunderstood the request or they didn't
have the information that they needed so
these are all what we call attributions
they're ways of explaining things when
things go wrong and we are making
attributions all day every day you know
we're making judgments about why it is
that something happened the way that it
did so there's a whole theory in
psychology around attribution theory and
what attribution theory suggests that
there are two different types of
attributions that we can make we can
make what are called dispositional
attributions and those are attributions
that are about the person so if you
found yourself writing things like you
know they're lazy uncommitted
incompetent anything of that sort those
would be dispositional or personal
attributions about why something went
wrong but then there's also situational
attributions and situational
attributions are attributing what it is
that went wrong two characteristics of
the situation so if you wrote things
like you know they need to catch the
train or they didn't have the
information that they should have been
given and so forth those are more
situational attributions and as you can
imagine the
situational attributions tend to be a
little bit more generous the thing is
that we tend to lean toward making more
dispositional attributions in general
and the reason that we make more
dispositional attributions or personal
attributions is because we don't have as
much information about why people are
doing what they're doing we have a lot
of information about why we're doing
what we're doing but not so much with
other people and then if they are in a
different location or in a different
country if they're in a different
culture and a different firm we have
even less information to help us explain
why it is they're doing what they're
doing so there's a natural tendency in
these cross-boundary teams to actually
make more of these have harsh personal
kinds of attributions and that really
fuels this us-versus-them dynamic you
know there's an in-group bias as well
which I'll talk a little bit about in a
minute so what can you do as leaders
when you see this us-versus-them dynamic
and I have to say it is almost
inevitable you probably will see it but
you can also do things to reduce the
likelihood of it showing up so what are
those there are three things I'm going
to talk about one is shared identity one
is Trust and then the third is
psychological safety and these are all
really intertwined their own mutually
supportive of one another so there's
that one that's more important than the
other you could actually start at any
one of these three and that would help
to erode some of the us-versus-them by
Dynamix that that you are seen or that
could happen in your team so we'll start
with shared identity this is just some
research that I did a while back with
mark Mortensen who's at INSEAD in France
we were looking at globally distributed
teams
and one of the things that we found was
that having a shared identity
significantly reduced the amount of
conflict that occurred on these teams
and in particular something called
effective conflict and that's where it
really gets personal so now having a
shared identity really helps to reduce
those negative attributions about the
person in particular and there's a ton
of research in social psychology that
looks at the importance of shared
identity and and having a vision this is
something that you can do in your teams
as leaders if people have a shared
vision they believe that they are
working toward a common goal but they
are all in it together that they are
interdependent and have to rely on one
another in order to be successful at
achieving their goals then you see a
shared identity develop very rapidly
quite strongly and the us-versus-them
dynamics can virtually disappear if
people are really focused on a strong
shared vision now the trick is that you
can start this now at the beginning of a
project people can be really bought in
everybody's really aligned with the
vision and see how others fit in and why
they need to work together but when
you're working across boundaries it
roads more rapidly you know if you are
not co-located people begin to make
sense of the vision in different ways if
you are from different disciplines
you may start to prioritize one element
over the other so it's something that
has to be complete continuously
revisited and reinforced in order to
ensure that that is still in place on an
ongoing basis so now we're going to talk
a little bit about trust and again these
are intertwined so it turns out that if
you've got a stronger shared identity
what comes with that is more trust and
if you've got more trust it's easier to
build a shared identity so with trust
I'd like you to bring to mind somebody
that you really trust so just for a
second you know think of somebody and
then again just jot down you know a
couple of characteristics that lead you
to trust this person I'll give you a few
seconds to write those down okay so you
might have written a whole host of
things like you know they they care
about you they always do what they say
you know they they know what they're
doing you know I'm sure there's a whole
variety of things that you wrote down
what I'm going to show you now is
definition of trust and then what some
of the different elements are that have
been found to compose trust and
trustworthiness so Trust is assured
reliance on the character ability or
truth of someone or something somebody
in which you place confidence and a more
research-oriented definition the
willingness to be vulnerable to the
actions of another person based on the
expectation that that other person will
perform a particular action it's
important to you the trustor
irrespective of your ability to monitor
or control that person so that a couple
things I want to pull out of that
definition one is trust is really about
being vulnerable so it's only really
trust if you've ended up in a situation
where you actually depend upon that
person and you've trust them to actually
do what it is you need done and they've
said they would do and importantly it's
irrespective of the ability to monitor
or control the person you know some
people say that you know you trust but
control the truth is they're different
things and oftentimes when you are
especially geographically distributed
it's really difficult to monitor control
so trust becomes even more important in
these situations and that's also true
when you're crossing other kinds of
boundaries you know when you're working
across firm
it's true when you're walking working
across disciplines where you actually
don't have enough knowledge of that
discipline to evaluate whether or not
what they're doing is appropriate or
correct then you really are vulnerable
to they're those their actions and Trust
is required okay so there are three
elements of trust that have been
identified in research
one is benevolence so benevolence is
really about whether or not the person
is caring and concerned about you
benevolence is you know at the extreme
is you know they will do something for
you even if they have to make a
sacrifice for themselves so you know if
you said that you know I trust this
person because they care about me I know
they'll do the right thing then that's
really benevolence the next one is
ability and this is something that
people often don't think about but
particularly in a work context we have
to believe that people can actually do
what it is they need to do in order to
trust them they have to have the
technical skills they have to have you
know the marketing savvy in order for us
to trust that they're going to be able
to fulfill their obligations to us and
then there's integrity and integrity is
really about reliability predictability
honor do they have a code by which they
are operating that you can count on
doesn't necessarily need to be the same
code as yours but you can count on it
you know what it is to expect of them
and the three of these compose trust and
trustworthiness a couple of things that
are interesting to know is that
different people value the different
elements differently so you may be
somebody where your whole list was all
about a benevolence but somebody else
might really think it's all about
ability and you know they really want to
work with people that are the most
capable and they don't worry too much
about the others so it's not a bad
conversation to have to understand you
know what people are really valuing
and to to use that as a lens to evaluate
whether or not you know you you can
assess them as trustworthy okay so if
we're talking about cross-boundary teams
missed our next poll is they're
generally left trust on cross-boundary
teams or more trust so take that ten
seconds for you to answer this poll okay
and this can be any kind of
cross-boundary team
all right the poll has ended and we're
gonna wait just a couple of seconds
while we get the results of the poll to
see whether or not people think there's
going to be more or less or no
difference from these teams all right
well this is interesting
okay so most people 231 of the
respondents thought that there would be
less trust on these cost cross boundary
teams handful thought to be about the
same and a few people thought you
actually could end up with more trust on
these teams so we thought that there
would be less trust on these teams and
set out to do a research study to see
the extent to which that was true and
what we found was in fact it was about
the same so these in particular were
geographically co-located versus
distributed teams and they were also
there were construction engineering
teams so we had some architects some
people in construction and you know
variety of other disciplines in there so
they were geographically distributed and
and also from different disciplines but
as you can see you know we looked at
month one when they form these teams and
month three and it didn't really seem to
matter very much so that that kind of
surprised us and we dug a little deeper
into the data to see what was going on
and what we saw was that on the
co-located teams it was much more
volatile so we ended up with dramatic
increases in trust but also dramatic
decreases
trust and we think that had a lot to do
with the fact that when you're
co-located you can actually see people's
behavior more you've got more
information about whether or not they
are caring toward other people whether
or not they are capable whether or not
they do have integrity so yeah we got
increases and decreases as people
adjusted their levels of trust and the
distributed teams there was a lot less
adjustment people started with a certain
level of trust at the beginning and that
was maintained throughout and looking at
this a little bit more closely what we
saw was in co-located teams people paid
attention to the behavior whether or not
people were following through their team
members were following through and that
affected whether or not they were
trustworthy and then that affected their
trust later in the process but in the
distributed teams
it started with perceived
trustworthiness so very quickly people
you know team members evaluated whether
or not somebody was trustworthy then
when they saw their behaviors they
looked at those behaviors through that
lens of being trustworthy or not and
then the attributions were aligned with
whether or not they thought they were
trustworthy and then that affected trust
later in the game so basically what this
shows is that establishing trust really
early in these cross-boundary teams is
crucial because once it gets established
the updating doesn't happen as
dynamically as it does on teams where
there's a lot more similarity and in
particular when people are co-located
and have more information about what
people are doing all right so now we'll
talk a little bit about psychological
safety and psychological psychological
safety is is pretty closely related to
trust when you have more trust people
feel more safe psychologically and if
you've got more psychological safety
people are more trusting and then the
same thing with shared identity
so psychological safety is defined as a
shared belief that's held by a team that
the team is safe for interpersonal
risk-taking this was a idea that was
developed by Amy Edmondson at Harvard
Business School about 20 years ago
there's been a ton of research on
psychological safety now establishing it
as an important predictor of team
success and particularly team innovation
in many places around the globe the
basic idea here is that people need to
feel safe sharing unpopular opinions
sharing knowledge pointing out errors
talking about mistakes that they've made
it's basically an environment where
people feel like they are supported by
one another and there's not you know
competition and undermining going on by
members of the team so this is really
crucial for innovation in general and
particularly when you have
cross-boundary teams psychological
safety has been shown to have
significant impact impacts on team
performance on team problem-solving and
particularly on learning and innovation
in teams and the interesting thing about
psychological safety is that it is
significantly affected by leader
behavior that is one of the number-one
predictors of whether or not you'll have
psychological safety is whether or not
the leader sort of sets the tone for
people to feel comfortable and again
this has been done around the globe
for example when leaders are open
accessible available to you know the
people that they're working with when
they model psychological safe behaviors
they talk about mistakes that they've
made they don't punish or degrade people
who have failed but really use that as a
learning opportunity all of that
behavior by leader
leads to higher levels of psychological
safety and then one additional practice
I wanted to share with you is team
reflection so this can really help
increase psychological safety as well as
trust where teams actually you know take
15 minutes on occasion maybe once a
month or so to just reflect on how
things are going you know are they happy
with their performance that are happy
with the process of a happy with the way
that they're working together how might
they improve their ability to work
together you know what are the
strategies that they might use in order
to get better performance and feel
better about the process the interesting
thing is it's sort of like exercising
regularly even though you know it's good
for you it doesn't always happen
spontaneously people are really busy
people are focused on the work that they
need to get done so it is really
important that the context be set for
this to happen you know with a leader
for example says okay you know we are
going to do this you know every month or
it's some specified interview interval
and time is actually made for it
reflective teams are more effective but
you've got to make the commitment to
that all right so just to serve
summarize what we've talked about here
shared identity is a really powerful
condition for teams and that can be
established with a common vision you
know making sure that people understand
their interdependences what it is
they're working on together and continue
to reinforce that over time with trust
be vigilant against harsh attributions
one of the ways to do this is to always
seek clarifying information you know if
you find yourself making harsh
attributions about you know particularly
people you know in these cross
boundaries situations or you see team
members making harsh attributions
personal kinds of attributions though
it's good to ask the question well what
else might be going on here
now what other information could I get
to help me to understand what really is
the reason behind this behavior and that
can really defuse the harsh attributions
and increase trust and then with regard
to cycle psychological safety a leader
can be a role model by discussing
mistakes being respectful of others not
punishing failure expressing caring
concern about employees and so forth and
then team reflection can help with all
of this
alright so to wrap up on cross-boundary
teaming we've talked about some of the
core issues that occur when people are
working across these boundaries and
these us-versus-them dynamics and merge
and you know I hopefully have convinced
you that you can still sustain higher
levels of performance and innovation by
fostering shared identity psychological
safety and higher levels of trust so
thank you very much we've got some time
for questions I'm going to turn it over
to sherry who is going to facilitate
that process so let's see so from our
participant here's like here's one
what's your advice for teams Pamela that
have very different business styles and
some of which may be cultural here's the
example specifically we work with a team
in Frankfort that's very cautious
methodical and adverse to failure our
scientists and engineers in San Jose are
more aggressive with innovation and
willing to accept small failures to
advance more quickly to a final
successful design how do they compromise
yeah that's a really good question it is
something that I talk about much more
extensively in the course the cultural
differences and in particular
differences in practices one of the
things that that I found in my research
where we've looked at innovation and
innovation practices in different parts
of the world is that you know there are
different approaches to innovation and
in fact what we found is that some of
the things like rapid iteration
that is so touted in you know the
Silicon Valley in the u.s. culture
actually can have negative effects in
some other cultural contexts so I think
it's really important to know that what
works for innovation in one culture may
not work in another culture and I think
the first thing to do is to figure out
what what the best practices are for
innovation in the culture in which
you're working because it may not be the
same and then figure out how to you know
I don't know I don't know if you want to
compromise or if you want to allow
multiple practices to coexist in order
to get the most out of different people
or maybe try out different practices and
see what that generates but I do think
that it's really important to start with
the practice and understand how those
differ in different cultures and not
only national cultures but also in
functional cultures you know different
professions have very very different
practices and and really understanding
those can help to figure out how to work
together and achieve high levels of
innovation in a United Way thank you
we haven't know that it's been asking do
you think trust needs evidence to be
built hmm yeah that's a really
interesting question there is some
research that talks about something
called Swift trust so Swift trust does
not need evidence to be built Swift
trust happens because you've got
information that gives you confidence
that this person should be trusted so
for example you know you it's somebody
that's been recommended to you by
somebody else that you trust a lot or
they've gone to you know a top-tier
University and gotten good grades well
then you might automatically think that
they're going to be
you know a really competent capable
person so there's there's a lot of
information that we look to in our
environment to figure out whether or not
somebody should be trusted and and you
know we can look at that evidence to
build this Swift trust you know or maybe
some of these licensed in a particular
field so there is this Swift trust it
doesn't last forever though as you are
working with somebody you are always
getting evidence about trust and
trustworthiness so so yes certainly over
time
you do need evidence in order to I
wouldn't say determine your level of
trust but adjust your level of initial
trust that was formed the challenge is
that we the way that we process that
information can sometimes be biased
because we don't have full information
and these attributions are at play so we
may see evidence of something for
example somebody not delivering a report
on time and we may then have our trust
lowered as a result of that when in fact
there might have been something else
going on so really important that you
know the trust and the attributions are
really intertwined and one of the things
that I really encourage on these
cross-boundary teams is to give people
the benefit of the doubt to trust them
first and then figure out what it is
that might have been going on great
here's one building trust with an
overseas team in Europe it's become very
challenging flow of information is one
way I don't get any information back
from them what are the options as a
participant might have yeah that's
another really good question tough
situation and you know it's not uncommon
to have these situations where you know
there's there's not enough communication
between teams or sub teams that are
located
in different parts of the globe that's a
couple of things I try one is that's
more likely to happen if there isn't a
strong sense of interdependence yet they
if they really rely on you for their
success then they should be in contact
with you more frequently so that you
know that there's something going on
they are potentially so that might mean
that you know there's not the kind of
shared identity and it's not the kind of
shared vision that needs to be present
in order for that team to function as
effectively as they need to you know the
other thing that can happen is you know
people just get really busy I've seen a
lot of teams where there's just not very
much communication from one location and
it's because there's just a lot going on
that we don't even know about at that
location so it's another case where I
think you know it's it's always good to
if you can send a text message or pick
up the phone you know during their
daytime hours and just check in with
somebody that you feel like you've got a
good rapport with and say hey you know
just checking in on you know what's
going on over there I wanted to see you
know if there's anything that we should
know about you know what's happening in
your world there right now in order to
get a better sense of why they might not
be responding as quickly as you'd hope
this was a good advice another that have
been asking you to clarify what that
team reflection could look like mmm
right yeah so team reflection oftentimes
it's just a really informal process so
getting team members in the room and you
know just you know asking the question
how are things going or getting in the
room either virtually or in person it's
good to have it happen in person but
often times that is not possible better
to have it on video then just audio when
you're doing these kinds of reflections
because those additional cues where you
can see people's facial expressions and
gestures can be really useful in a
reflective kind of activity and you know
you might want to use a process where
people are able to you know write down
on post-it notes or something you know
what they think is going well and where
they think the opportunities are for
improvement in either their you know
their performance or in their group
process and then you know talk through
those and you know ideally have an open
conversation where people can you know
articulate what it is that is working
for them and is not working for them and
then identify some strategies you know
what could we do in the next week in
order to help us improve on this
particular element and again you know
just having a really you know open you
know not rushed kind of context and if
it's done regularly then people get
accustomed to doing it okay you talked a
lot about building trust early we're
getting several questions on how do you
backup from a team that's become
dysfunctional so how do you rebuild
trust when it's been shattered and
respective non-existent hmm yeah that
that is really challenging I think my
inclination would be to go with one of
the other two boxes on the chart
psychological safety is probably has
also probably been undermined on that
team and people may have lost sight of
why they need one another and why they
want to build trust and work together so
I would probably start with the shared
identity piece and really helping people
to see why this whole group is in the
room why they depend upon each other and
why it's really important to rebuild the
bonds that they have and I think it's
important to name it too you know to say
now look trust has broken down whole
variety of reasons for why that might
have happened let's use some techniques
- excuse me rebuild that and and and
create a higher level of psychological
safety and again both with this question
and the previous question the leader
modeling is really important in this so
you know the leader you know saying you
know we've you know had some breakdowns
and Trust I hold some of the
responsibility for this I want to
rebuild it and with psychological safety
the leader showing some vulnerability
talking about mistakes and so forth all
of that that's openness and it's really
it's challenging because when Trust
isn't there the openness is hard and it
can be misinterpreted so in it you kind
of have to take baby steps in order to
help rebuild and sometimes it does help
to get a facilitator in you know if
Trust is really damaged it can help to
get a mediator in that can help
facilitate those conversations here's a
question that's addressing language
issues I'm an American that my team is
located in Brazil
well my Portuguese is usually adequate
there are times when I sense frustration
on the part of my colleagues when I ask
them to repeat things how would you
advise team members to be more effective
communicators when the primary language
used for business isn't their first
language yeah that's that's a great
question
language is really challenging and
that's another segment that's covered in
the course you know language challenges
you know both professional languages and
Asha and you know national language is a
couple things on that one is that we
need to recognize and this isn't always
recognized that fluent does not mean
fluent when somebody is
doing business in a language that is
their non-native language it is more
challenging for them they tend to be it
takes more cognitive effort there might
be vocabulary the vocabulary that they
don't have access to they may have an
accent may mispronounce things and so
forth and and oftentimes native speakers
and this particularly true of native
English speakers in part because of the
where cultures operate as well we tend
not to be as patient as we could be with
that so I think part of it is just
building an appreciation on both sides
for what it means and what the
experience is of somebody who is having
to operate in a non-native language and
what the experience is of somebody who
is a native language speaker of the
chosen language the lingua franca and
having to sort of slow down their
processes in order to work effectively
in those teams so in particular with
your question and I think part of it is
you know just letting the team members
that you're working with in Brazil know
that that you are trying really hard
that you are attempting to speak
Portuguese but you know you don't have
the same level of fluency and that you
really appreciate their patience in you
know allowing you to to you know to
occasionally not be as articulate as you
would be in your native language so this
one but a lot of this is about a
perspective taking and understanding
what people are experiencing so you are
talking about harsh attribution one of
our participants is saying they see
issues of harsh attribution happening in
this case between male and female
colleagues which is escalating very
quickly
they fix that interesting harsh
attributions between male and female
colleagues so I'm just kind of thinking
through this it sounds like it's an
us-versus-them problem we tend to see
more harsh attributions when people see
people as others so it's a little hard
to know without knowing more about the
situation but I think the core of the
problem is that they're subgrouping
going on and for some reason there is
you know the the the women are feeling
ostracized by the men or vice versa and
that that needs to be resolved in order
for these harsh attributions to diminish
my guess is that for some reason there
isn't a sense of psychological safety
for either the men or the women in this
group so that might be something to talk
about it might be worth having
you know conversation about what it is
that's going on and they're also
potentially there could be competition
that's going on there might be a feeling
of powerlessness in one group or the
other that is leading to this so I would
I would try to dig a little bit deeper
to investigate what the source is of
this division this sub-grouping that's
happening between the genders and
sometimes it can actually be something
in the content of what you're working on
for example if you know the women are
responsible for a particular part of the
project and the men are protective
responsible for another particular part
of the project that can set up this
dynamic as well great
asking here for recommendations on
virtual team-building exercises what is
this some of the kinds of things teams
can do to build that trust Minh yeah
yeah so a lot of people what they want
to do is get everybody together in a
neutral location for a couple of days of
team-building I am actually not a fan of
that at all you know if you've got a lot
of money and a lot of time great
something to do but I don't think it
it's that the half-life is relatively
short of those activities and the reason
the half-life is short is because you're
not getting at the core issues that get
in the way and the core issues are
really the work and how people do the
work and when you're off team building
that's not what people are doing you
know they're yeah you're getting to know
one another your understanding
personalities and so forth so it's good
you know I'm not saying it's not a good
thing but I'm a real advocate for having
people travel to the location of the
other site or sites they're working with
and not just the manager but the team
members travel so that they can see the
context in which one another are working
you know it with the example from
Frankfort
you know where the you know their
innovation approach is very different
it's really good to go and actually sit
side-by-side and see how people are
working and and who talks to them and
what their office space looks like and
what they do for lunch and the cultural
context in which they're embedded that
has a much more profound effect on
collaboration going forward than
team-building kinds of activities thank
you so much Pamela we really want to
thank you for your time today we hope
you enjoyed the hour and we encourage
you to check out all of our offerings at
SCPD stanford.edu and again don't forget
that you'll be receiving a recording of
this webinar to share with your friends
and colleagues have a great day
you